yeah man name is sharp you catch me man
on the bootleg kev podcast you know it's
going down like the ground that we walk
on come get all my time zone man
boo lay cat podcast special guest in
here you know the [ __ ] it is let's talk
about it sharp
let's get it welcome so thank you for
having me first of all um
i have quite a history in las vegas you
know i used to do uh
afternoons at hot 97.5 out there
so right on the street somebody heard
you once or twice i used to live off of
the 15 in craig
yeah no that's that that's out of north
yeah north side yes north
and uh yeah man i love vegas is uh
kind of my i love it out there man
that's like one of my second if i like
like my second home low key you know
what i mean so
you know you're a vegas guy yeah i love
vegas man i'm saying it's definitely
yeah vegas my that's my home too for
sure yeah and they go yeah man it's my
spots how long um like
so were you originally from san diego or
vegas no i'm originally from detroit
okay originally from detroit how long
have you been in the west coast [ __ ] man
my mama moved me to the west coast so i
was probably like two one and a half two
so when i was in so being born in
detroit i never uh like i like i said i
can't tell you no streets are nothing
out there right question questions
because i never lived out there but i
moved to the west coast and like i said
man [ __ ] all my people been taking me to
daigo [ __ ] so i was like
12 13. yeah i'm saying start riding with
my homies and [ __ ] you know i kind of
got a lot of my season from around there
you know especially bouncing back from
both places you know what i'm saying
because vegas is fast just within itself
vegas is crazy i was their main [ __ ]
before some of the casinos got torn down
you know they were wild yeah no for sure
man it's definitely uh it changes every
day
the thing about vegas is like you said
like
you could go there
and not be there for like two months and
come back and be like the [ __ ] they put
how they build this so fast or they
knock this [ __ ] down or this [ __ ] got
thrown up it's crazy yeah let you know
that life moves without you whether
you're there or not 100 man no just the
whole like uh vegas lifestyle is one
like once you leave vegas it's very hard
to shake that lifestyle like it took me
a while to like
get back into like normal like i've been
trying to leave night clubs holding
drinks and [ __ ]
and all the [ __ ] closed down at two
o'clock a lot of other places hell the
whole city shuts down you know vegas 24
7. man you can get whatever whenever
however 24 hours a day seven days a week
the uh yeah and then obviously just the
hustle out there it's crazy because
vegas is like i feel like
it really helped me to live there
because it kind of put a permanent
battery in my back that never went away
yeah cause i feel like the city of vegas
you got to be out there
grinding this is a hospitality city like
everyone's on the grind like whether
you're parking cars whether you're
[ __ ]
you know i think that's probably why
um
no artists really blew up out of there
not saying there hasn't been people
that's came out of there because there
has been and they don't claim it they
won't say hey i'm from
las vegas you know they'll be the
closest was probably dizzy dizzy right
dizzy dizzy claims obviously baby keems
from vegas he's on tour with kendrick
yeah but there's was a lot of great
artists that just didn't get over the
top yeah you know what i think i think
it's because and just just my outlook to
it like i think it's because there's
really no uh
not everybody see in vegas
vegas and atlanta are different because
atlanta they really support their home
artists right they'll really like shut
everything down to go to you know say
somebody's concert and really go and
support as of in vegas like it's it's a
melting pot because everybody really
deep down inside everybody's from
somewhere somewhere else for the most
part right like a lot of people from the
bay a lot of people from l.a you know
what i'm saying like the the the uh
percentage of lost vegans are slim
they're slim so you know people think
that these are a bunch of vegas people
know these are people from everywhere
yeah shit's a melt and pop people are
here today going tomorrow you got here
for a job and where they they running or
whatever it is people are here today
gone tomorrow you know what i'm saying
so there's different type of [ __ ] and
different type of whether it's hustles
or people scamming whatever there's
there's new [ __ ] daily coming through
that city you know what i'm saying so i
think that's why it's always constantly
changing but even back to like just the
artists nobody's trying to help each
other because everybody's just trying to
help themselves yeah when i was there
like we had like a underground show on
sunday nights on the radio so we play
like [ __ ] interstate fats radio
ramone [ __ ] [ __ ] with interstate fats
i think uh yeah one of our old schools
in his video him in uh lausanne hmm
fast is great free fats man i've just
texted yeah that's my guy yeah he's a
good guy
a beast yeah you be sweetie now you're
beats with it for sure um so
i think like would you say like you kind
of originally came onto the scene in
terms of people knowing who you are
outside of your city or your friend's
circle due to the soft white belly uh
videos yeah software underbelly yeah
shout out mark like that that's work
ladies i loved your guys's interview
when you had them on your show too that
[ __ ] was done yeah that one that one
right there uh
that one touched me man because it was
really like a
you know just a revolving door it was a
full circle moment you know what i'm
saying to sit there with him it actually
like made me feel a certain kind of way
because i'm like damn you know i'm i'm
here you know and me doing what i did
with him
made me
step my game up some and like i said bro
i never expected none of that [ __ ] man i
just i got into it i got a chance at it
and i don't like to uh disappoint myself
anything that i've ever done i like to
be great at and i ain't done a lot i'm
saying but whatever i did do i made sure
i was great at and i made sure i was
great to me um you know so i did the i
did the interview with him like when i
went on there bro i promise you man i
didn't even expect it like the comments
was bad you know i didn't really i'm
like man i'm not used to it i'm from the
street anybody got something to say to
you they gonna say it to your face you
know so it's different when you see a
bunch of trolls or a bunch of people
sitting there making all these these
comments you know what i'm saying that
you don't even really know who it is
[ __ ] like man lock him up why
is this type of person outside i'm like
whoa
what the [ __ ] right i'm just telling you
i'm saying my past or things
are telling my story but man people get
so [ __ ] captivated and wrapped up and
like
they they feel like their way should be
is the right like i'm saying that that's
what should happen to you or this is
where you should be you said because you
do something that ain't you know
it's not valued to society but [ __ ] what
is
what really is man i mean [ __ ] who they
call me the kick i'm saying the kettle
black like ooh
also like i don't think people
understand like the culture of las vegas
to be 100 honest like at the end of the
day like if you're from vegas like it's
not crazy to think that like
you know
pimps exist and they're normal people i
know that's a crazy thing let me tell
you something it's not just vegas it's
anywhere it's anywhere but specifically
like like it's like vegas is like it's
like a part of the culture there like
they just say that because it comes with
a lot of gambling drinking and
prostitution so you would think that it
it resonates with that and it does but
that shit's been going on everywhere
chicago bay i mean whatever city you're
in yeah
the longest so i can't sit there and
just pinpoint vegas and say oh yeah you
know that's the
the mecca of it because it's not it's
man that shit's all over it's it's it's
got its pieces everywhere to me
you know what i'm saying because when i
was moving i seen it everywhere it
wasn't just my city that's why
[ __ ] got to really get out of
their backyard
you know i got out of the backyard so i
got to see okay they moving like this
over here or you know they were first
time
any sort of interaction with pimps in
vegas there's a place next to little
darlings that i don't know if it's there
anymore used to be called kelly's casino
kelly's you know kelly's i was there for
many years yo kelly's i was there they
tore down they ain't there anymore this
is a wild place no more i've seen a lot
of crazy [ __ ] girls i remember because
my homie one of my best friends was
nancy working when you were up in there
older white lady probably so
one of my best friends
so one of my one of my close homies at
the radio station was my boy ron dizzle
and ron was not 21. so the only place i
could take him was [ __ ] little
darlings and we were [ __ ] with a
couple of [ __ ] and little darlings
so i used to be they'd let him in
kelly's casino though yeah so we used to
just go get shit-faced to kelly's casino
with a bunch of pimps and hoes and then
[ __ ] walk over walk across the
parking lot and go to the [ __ ] little
deer it was it was definitely uh a cool
like waiting place you had to stand in
that square and get buzzed into the bar
yeah it was it was a cool place like you
know what i'm saying to like pass time
in between time while you're waiting to
make a move or waiting to do something
but that [ __ ] got bad after a while like
people are starting to get beat up every
night
like [ __ ] police up there a lot
now because [ __ ] be tripping in
the parking lot it got real ugly yeah
hairy for sure it got ugly after a while
bro i watched all that [ __ ] crazy um so
like obviously
when i grew up man you mentioned the
movie american pimp when you first got
here you just interviewed the guy from
there yeah yeah
i remember watching american pimp and
what was the one that had mr white folks
in it um there was another pimp
documentary that was crazy
uh there was like two
white folks was my partner
so but he was a part he was in a movie i
knew i knew him um
but but just like the culture of the
pimp [ __ ] was so mainstream back then
like they remember they used to have the
um
what was the [ __ ] party in vegas that
they would have
was it pimps and players or
you know what i'm talking about it
wouldn't be in vegas no no no no it was
like a theme night at a nightclub that
was like huge it was not like obvious
like oh i don't know nobody that was
playing like that um i wouldn't even pay
that i probably don't know because i
wouldn't have paid that type of [ __ ] no
money it was before i even lived there
like a theme in something yeah but um
it's crazy because you actually won you
won player of the year right or pimp of
the year was it i don't recall none of
that you don't recall i don't remember
that uh fair enough i don't i don't
remember any that type of [ __ ] um
but like
for you like um
do you feel like in 2022
has like that hustle had to evolve with
like
obviously the only fans of the worlds
coming up or you know some of the some
of the um
i guess technology that you know back in
the day i guess it was a little
different now we're like nowadays women
really don't got to leave the crib to to
hit a lick
that's not necessarily true man because
you know i mean there's chicks i'm sure
eating off only fans but not everybody's
eating off only fans you know it sounds
easier said than done because you know
you got to keep up with content i'm sure
on there and not to mention you got to
make sure that uh
you're bringing something new to the
table every time because you know the
the fans that might be spinning with you
you know they're getting tired of seeing
you do the same old okey-dokey trick you
know and then also that shit's on the
internet forever it's on there it's on
there forever you know the like i said
the game that i came from bro it was a
secret society like you know a chick can
hold for 20 years or you know whatever
the case may be and they people would
never know you know but they're taking
care of it on a whole different end
because it wasn't something that you had
to glorify you just knew what it was
yeah you know what i'm saying now if you
know you know type [ __ ] everything neat
every everybody trying to glorify
everything now now a label got a stand
for everything you know to me anymore
man i say [ __ ] a label i'm more into the
art if you think about it too like
labels suck because someone puts a label
on you like bro i'm so much more than
whatever you think boxes it boxes you in
as a human being to people's perception
yeah yeah it does you seem to have like
right away man
kill it like i remember watching the
first few episodes of your podcast and
i feel like
you you just are a natural at this [ __ ]
man like and i i love i think your
interviews are um
they bring something different to like
no jumper just podcasting in general
like i love i love when you do
interviews i love your approach doing
interviews i love the guests you have
you had my homie caskey on yeah that's
my partner um you had yada on shout out
to yada from vegas um
but uh
how hard has it been like i guess
adjusting in a new space man where
you're talking to people where you're on
camera where you're like your
personality which is something i'm sure
has always been very prevalent in your
life but now the rest of the world
no sharp knows you for your personality
man it's uh
it's definitely different
because
you know i'm not used to and i'm not
trying to say this in no like no funny
way or nothing but like i'm not used to
working with people or i'll say people
who don't who haven't done what i've
done
so it's different dealing with you know
the square aspect of things you know and
having to be somewhere on time you know
hey you got to do this i never had
nobody tell me to do anything in my
[ __ ] life only than what i i
wanted right so you know just kind of
being on just like you know uh
a different time zone with it you know a
little bit more structure than you used
to do a little bit more structure than
what i'm used to but then again you know
i'm used to building structures so you
know i got to be able to take what i
give mm-hmm if that makes any sense
so i came in i came in fast and just
tried to just you know just adapt
because you know i'm a type of person
man that i've come from many situations
and have had to adapt
so i feel like this is just one of many
that i've had to adapt to
i would like to say that my favorite
[ __ ] you did was the tucker the toe
sucker [ __ ] yeah everybody everybody
like that everybody want me to come back
and do another one of that one with that
guy yeah everybody's like man do another
one but i'm like
they were what they they listen man i
think that dude's from my hometown so
i'm from phoenix i'm pretty sure he's
from everybody listen everybody always
says like you know bring back the
confrontational ones or do this one or
do that one but i'm like they were
organic when they happen this ain't no
script yeah you can't run that back
again with that same energy
not even that but like i'm not trying to
come back like that [ __ ] happened the
way that it happened like i didn't plan
that [ __ ] it wasn't no okay we're gonna
go in here we're gonna get to bumping
heads no if a [ __ ] could say
some old weird [ __ ] or some off the wall
[ __ ] hey i don't agree with that i think
that i'm older bro you have to
understand something like a lot of these
people that and i've said this before on
another podcast like a lot of the people
that i interview um um 12 13 years their
senior bro so it's a huge gap in the
mental capacity of what i hold and what
they hold they're just now getting
around to it bro do you getting their
nipples wet
you know what i'm saying or you i'm
saying mother getting harder like they
just getting around to doing something
like that like i've been around the
block call me seven eight ninety
thousand [ __ ] times so like these
these are kids to me
i'm saying but we don't we don't hold
that respect no more for people that
come from you know hey man i've been
here before you i know better scenes
yeah i've seen some things yeah they
don't listen to us oh [ __ ] you you just
oh like yo yo
yo your mindset or what you got to offer
ain't gonna get me nowhere because today
knowledge isn't i said it earlier today
and it was crazy because i thought about
i'm like not people don't like knowledge
because you can't spend it um it's not
it's not a tangible currency it's not
tangible currency they can't walk in the
mall and spin the knowledge you give
them they're not looking at it that hey
it can look out for you in the long run
yeah they're not looking at it like that
man that's some real [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying they're not looking at it
like that's why knowledge has been the
book that's the the lowest of the low of
value right now on in currency and it
should be the highest it should be the
number one most priceless thing i think
knowledge and time
i'm saying like but come on man like
even with even with it runs hand in hand
yeah for knowledge and time but it's
like people need to really look at it
like that knowledge is everything and
what you can take in what you can how
much of it you can consume it's
priceless it'll help you in the long run
hey what up it's bootleg kev we got to
stop the interview to tell you what our
good friends at my bookie football
season has started my favorite time of
the year because i love to gamble on
football it makes watching football so
much fun it's my like literally i just
love watching football and i love it
even more when i got money on the line
and no matter where you are right now
what state what country you can get in
on the action it's winning season go to
my bookie sign up for a new account
register and get that double deposit
bonus using the promo code bootleg now
let me tell you what that means that
means when you go to my bookie let's say
you make a 250 deposit using the promo
code bootleg you'll have 500 to gamble
with that's right they're gonna double
your [ __ ] money right now they got
the prop builder you could bet on uh
whether or not i don't know
well matthew stafford throw for three
touchdowns will kylo murray rush for a
touchdown you could put all those on one
thing and secure the [ __ ] bag
all right get online with your boy let's
get this money together my bookie go
sign up with that promo code bootleg and
double your deposit right now go
register do you feel like um you're kind
of experiencing because i feel like
you've had some really dope deep
conversations on your podcast that are
[ __ ] incredible
but the [ __ ] that always goes viral is
like when you get into one of these
confrontations that goes crazy and like
it's like okay that [ __ ] is cool and
like you said it was an organic
conference yeah it's not like you're
planning that [ __ ] to go run back right
i don't want to run that back that's
fake to me you know what i'm saying like
that's not how it landed everything
happened the way that it happened you
got to catch it real life in real time
100 man
is there anything like um
that you feel like you've improved upon
since you started the podcast like just
in terms of like i've i think i've
improved a lot like in you know just
trying to take my time more with things
but you know
i feel like people only critique
themselves to the viewer but you're
still watching you what you should want
this to be organic you should not want
this to be because your comments change
the narrative now and it's what it is
now that then got watered down that
means everybody can [ __ ] do it right
and not everybody can do it so sit the
[ __ ] back let me grab the steering wheel
let me drive don't try to put your hand
on it you're turning right i'm turning
left we're bound to [ __ ] crash don't
do me got you you know what i'm saying
let us take the steering wheel let us do
what we're doing that's what makes it
captivating real conversation and i've
said it before well overall real people
and like i think people obviously
gravitate to you because [ __ ]
those are some of the highest uh view
counts on uh software underbelly are
your interviews like people obviously
really gravitate to you because i think
you're pretty unapologetic i mean i'll
say this i feel like there's some people
that's probably whooped me but they were
on some weird [ __ ] like it was some it
wasn't like hey people hate you they're
gonna watch you
as well like yeah people hate you
because they want to have something to
talk about like i like to go back to
like some of my interviews i've done
even though i got a lot of them that's
done numbers gold but some of the ones
that i really was like this was a good
one right here was it was it had
information it had knowledge it was
showing you where this person's been
where they're where they're at today and
where they're headed it's got all of the
the missing pieces of the puzzle to
become a masterpiece you know a one of
one and a lot of people won't though
they won't watch that one as much as
they'll watch the confrontational one
because they like drama they like
confrontation they don't want to learn
anything that's why i told you knowledge
is at an all-time low you should be
wanting to take this [ __ ] and run with
this and apply it to your life
somebody's trying to give it up to you
take that [ __ ] man because ain't [ __ ]
for free in this world but an [ __ ]
but not say it before man sometimes you
can't even get that for free ain't that
the truth for real what's a couple of
the interviews that you wish more people
would have watched
but you're like man this one was special
like i really wish this would have went
crazier for the right reasons there was
a there was a couple man you know um
one of the first ones that i did that
didn't have any confrontation my boy
cookie man
uh tooky blunt he owns a dispensary out
in the bay
and you know he went through hell man
business partners robbing him like he
teared up like he was sad because he
really trusted these people you know
what i'm saying they have to bounce back
by himself right
and really like try to bring it to the
forefront where he's sitting there now
telling his story like it was it was
definitely captivating it was i i feel
like this man like there's a lot of them
that just need to be watched like don't
just look for the controversy come and
get the knowledge too because to me
there's countless ones i feel like i've
done that they deserved more that's fair
you know what i'm saying they deserved
more man but hey who am i
that would make me i can't critique that
because that would turn me to a viewer
and i just want them to do what they do
organically but just
don't just always look for the drama
look for some knowledge too and
something you can gain because that time
that you sat there and even just watched
that [ __ ] or somebody get into it
you could have spent learning something
as well um
that's real you don't get your time back
i don't care if you also i just want any
[ __ ] minutes i also feel like
even when you're getting in it into it
with people it's almost from like a
place of like frustration where it's
like yo are you [ __ ] you know a place
of passion right right right because
and all in all i give a [ __ ] about
people bro
and you know sometimes you got to give
people tough love you got to tell them
what they need to hear versus what they
want to hear everybody's been cushioned
by that man
we've cushioned ourselves with that here
in america bro and we got to stop doing
that to each other we got to stop lying
to each other and overall to ourselves
i feel you on that if we don't make come
on bro when do we when do we break that
cycle it seems like it's getting softer
it's not getting any stronger
uh let's switch it up okay you're a
vegas guy
all-time great give me your top four
vegas strip clubs of all time open
closed
i'll throw one out first let's go with
strip hop that strip hop error was
special that's seamless it was that like
was it seamless right there off of our
arms yeah yeah i remember it everybody
used to slide through that [ __ ]
frannie was djing and i remember that
[ __ ] was cool rick ross and me
sliding yeah yeah yeah they used to pop
i remember that joint um
palomino's a classic palomino's a class
in the north it's out north it's right
there next to a little small spot named
chicas bonitas oh yeah that sits right
next to it i believe a little small hole
and rhinos probably like the german
rhinos spearmint rhino
that's
good
wings
tourist spot you know um ice always i
always just love me some crazy wars
crazy horse back in the day or the new
one the new one yeah yeah the new ones
actually got this one that's true the
new one's got good sushi that went on
industrial for you is that the one under
the bridge yeah under the bridge they
tried to reopen it
yeah and then something [ __ ] happened
and they yeah they were weighed with it
what else um
hustlers cool i guess
hustlers are solid they're solid they're
all right
i like the little rooftop [ __ ] though
the rooftop was a vibe when they first
opened and they were throwing parties
and [ __ ] i think baby bash hosted some
[ __ ] up there yeah the rooftop was a
vibe yeah 100 did you ever um
obviously you know
i think molly mall is locked up right
now but were you ever close with maul or
did you ever go to any of his parties
back in the day no no no
yeah i know he had some crazy parties
i never did i'll tell you the truth
honestly i didn't like you can't say he
knows me i know him i don't know that's
fair we know i know of him i've heard of
his name but i've never i don't know
um
talk to me about
what's like in your opinion like you see
kind of like what ads done with
community and and kind of spinning off
no jumper is there anything else that
you're like currently working on like
got some stuff going but i just want to
i just want to bring it out i don't want
to talk about it in a while it's just
going to happen it's just going to
happen i got some big i got some big
plays coming though i feel like you
could write a book man yeah i think so i
think so probably good yeah probably
good what should we what should we call
it i don't know or like a netflix series
about your life okay so i'm gonna say
this right so if i uh
if like from all that you've heard so
far right like if you were sitting here
like you were a dude that like signs off
on the books like yeah this needs to be
a book
from what you've heard so far
what would you like what title would you
lean towards
oh
what title
pimping ain't easy
that's too easy
that's too easy it's the first thing
that popped up that's so easy
i would you know what i would probably
call it what
i would call it from from pimpin to
potton
from pimping to potting
that's great it'll barnes and noble near
you
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] great yeah show up to my
book signing [ __ ] hey for for uh
[Laughter]
oh that's great
not saying you in particular but for
like in general based on your experience
i think that like uh the the term
pimping has got a
a bad stigma to it obviously but like
i do feel like what you said earlier
about structure you're like yo i've
created structure so
i can take it how i give it
um would you say that that is the main
purpose of somebody who holds that title
not saying yourself i just mean in
general someone run that back to me
again
so the purpose of a pimp
you know in a girl's life who is that
why are you so curious about that
because i'm just curious like
if i'm not saying you i mean in general
would you say the main purpose of that
would be
structure
structure you know and i'll say this man
from what i've always seen the game as
and especially sitting back now and
looking in on it
it's i feel like
it's just coming together with somebody
that really understands what you're
doing because like i've said before and
i'll give i'll use you as an example
you work a regular 95 right now so you
work let's just say yeah okay okay fair
enough yeah you just they said you work
a regular 95 or whatever
and you come home
and you know you want a hot meal maybe
lay down with your chick you know watch
some netflix or something get rubbed
don't do what you do you know get up and
get ready to do your thing again in the
morning correct
could you accept when you come in and
you know you coming from a long day work
you're getting in the shower she's
getting out the shower to get ready to
go to work to go and [ __ ] with some
tricks
could you accept that
could i if i was working a nine-to-five
yeah could you accept that
just you're coming home every day and
that's what she's doing
it would depend on how i met you you're
in love with her oh man come on i'm in
love with her you're in love with her
you're in the whole city you're in a
whole relationship with her
if i was just a normal dude normal joe
schmoe probably not
i don't know i don't you have to think
about what i'm saying here okay do i
think i would give a [ __ ] yes i would
give a [ __ ] would you find me no [ __ ]
yes i'm not relationship yes yes i meant
i would probably not be okay with you
she was turning tricks yes yes i mean
would you be okay with her leaving every
night you don't know what she's doing
you just know she's getting some money
shane if i was to joe
i would say yeah i would probably be
like what the [ __ ] going on here yeah
you get what i'm saying yes how many you
have to think about it that's even
though okay you're a rare one of one
obviously
my bad but you have to think about how
many other people no no no i'm telling
you that if i was just a normal guy i
would give a [ __ ] i'd be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing and that's my point
like a mother is gonna give a [ __ ] so
there's a lot of chicks that aren't
gonna stop doing what they're doing
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying but they
still want to they're a woman they still
want affection they still yearn for
partner they still yearn for that nobody
wants to be alone the biggest baddest
[ __ ] that'll sit there and say
oh i'm independent i'm about just want
somebody mm-hmm you have a [ __ ] if it's
a [ __ ] a cat
a dog like [ __ ] is gonna want
something some sort of
affection sort of yeah or
friendship something some type of a
situationship relationship doesn't
matter they're gonna want it because in
this in this world
nobody's built to be alone um that's how
i feel nobody's able to be alone
everybody knows that deep down inside
they just can't find the [ __ ] words
you know what i'm saying because that's
what it really stems to to me everybody
and everybody wants to be wanted not
needed
so you're saying essentially essentially
companionship
but it's also obviously a business
relationship i mean
when you're in that wouldn't you want
some type of compensation
fair enough
i mean damn like if i'm going to put up
with all these guys running through you
know compensation what you're going to
sit there and say and do
yeah like i said either either there
that [ __ ] it isn't for everybody that's
fair and it seems like it's been a it's
a it's a dying game man it's a dying
breed you got to pick something else up
yeah well like nowadays you got like uh
you know
you got like guys like uh tyga like
launching like only fans agencies like
i mean [ __ ] adam manages girls on only
fans you know shout out to him getting
it get getting to it
the porn man
um have you like there's so many
different inner workings within the no
jumper universe between like uh just
politics or certain people don't [ __ ]
with it it just it seems like a lot
between
the flocco guy or there's like you know
there's just so many different
personalities
i see where you're going with it no bro
i got listen everybody got love for each
other there ain't no problem no but i
wasn't going to say that i was going to
ask you like is it is it is it is is it
like a more of a big family or does
everybody just kind of do their family
we all together even though we got to do
what we got to do separately that's what
makes us a team so
you know
it's been all gravy trained over there
everybody yeah everybody focused
everybody's buckling down i don't think
adam would have invested into even
having a new office a new building looks
crazy if and i don't think he would have
put that together if everybody was on
rocky terms or everybody's just kind of
doing their own thing no it's about
bringing ideas together and how can we
make this bigger hmm
that's fair man you know what i'm saying
how can we make this bigger but you know
we ain't just trying to bring on those
suckers so everybody stop trying to dm
trying to hey man we gotta start now man
come on man if it's going to happen for
you let it happen organically also like
i feel like everything like you said
it's got to be organic it's got to be
man you came in for an interview and
then from there it was like damn and
that's documented yeah you know what i'm
saying [ __ ] don't know go watch
it 100 you'll see for sure if you had to
pick a actor to play you in a netflix
mini-series about your life who would it
be man
who's playing sharp
who would play me let me see
got to be a light-skinned cat with some
white skin obviously
i ain't picking no damn terrance howard
neither
that ain't even i don't even want i want
something different terrance howard
yeah shout out to him but i just
couldn't no i'm saying because i'm
thinking light skin like i'm trying to
keep within my realm
but
um
i don't know
i couldn't tell you because i
to be honest with you i'm a hard act to
follow
okay you dig what i'm saying so i don't
really think anybody can
two play they would have to pick that
and hopefully he can he can nail it
i mean
just to be real to me thinking about
it's not coming to my mind because it's
not [ __ ] supposed to right that's how
i really feel about it you know what i'm
saying it's not supposed to i feel like
you put a lot of game out into the world
when's the last time somebody really
gave you some game or some advice that
you really held on to
i try to take some
hopefully i want to say every day
because anybody that i talk to i want to
be able to gain something from that
conversation even in this conversation
i'm saying i want to be able to leave
with something and
i'll sort through it to get mines you
ain't got to just give it to me as a as
a course here's this course that course
no however you run it i'll sort through
the laundry i'll find my size
so you're just always you're just oh i
mean i feel like always soaking up game
bro as you should man what i'm saying
always man i'll never stop man that
means i stop living if i'm doing that
how did you get the name sharp man
uh from one of my partners man from [ __ ]
man uh
shout out juice jones that's my partner
man i got that name in chicago i went
when i was probably
17. that was one of my first
cross-country endeavors
and i went cross-country and i was out
there in chicago for like two and a half
months three months trapping
and you know i was always a sharp dude
always dressed sharp so my partner was
just like man you sharp man you just you
always dress sharp and
it just it stuck with me and it just ran
with me for years chicago man chicago
for a few months at 17. yeah damn
how was that it was cool man just doing
what i knew yeah yeah doing what i knew
man that's a beautiful thing man it was
cool what was it like uh because san
diego is a pretty a a beautiful place
but also like i don't think people
understand like things can get hairy in
san diego oh for sure obviously uh
san diego's a real place for sure um
what would you say like the contrast
going back and forth from diego to vegas
was like how how do the cities
i guess how's the streets different well
i feel like
it's it's no different man it's just
different views it's just different ones
one's in the desert and one's by the
beach
you know what i'm saying by some water
like it doesn't it doesn't change like
there's no uh difference in the type of
[ __ ] that run around you're
saying it's just different it's just
different places man yeah that's the
problem [ __ ] always want to
like section off [ __ ] in this
section and that section but really
[ __ ] is just the same they just
look in different areas just different
areas man it's the west coast i think
everybody [ __ ] living damn
they're the same you know what i'm
saying paying rent the same
you know what i'm saying many life bills
the same
trying to you know i'm saying bad
[ __ ] the same like [ __ ]
there ain't nothing new i ain't seen
nothing new that [ __ ] is doing
in different places down here that it's
just like a one-off like wow hold on we
ain't seen that yet they they doing that
nah man everybody doing they're doing
what they do yeah everywhere
everywhere has its own politics
everyone's going to so i don't ever
really look at it as like too much
segregation man like because and all in
all we we are the same bro
at the end of it all i mean that's the
problem that's where we get it [ __ ] up
everybody like i said want to separate
[ __ ] or oh what do you think these
people are thinking about these people
over here man the same [ __ ]
thing you ever notice you probably know
me and plotting on you like it's the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] bro it doesn't
change so where were you like in swiss
your high school years where were they
predominantly in i didn't go to high
school i don't get kicked out in ninth
grade so ninth grade your freshman year
you were out of there i was gone bro
where were you at when that happened
vegas vegas yeah where high school were
you supposed to go to in vegas clark
shout out to clark went there [ __ ]
like three four months crazy three
months would you get kicked out for
knowing somebody had a pistol in school
or something but i already had the rap
sheet hella big so just that just threw
the icing on the cake and they said you
had already gotten into troubles yeah a
lot in school yeah i got in trouble a
lot in school man someone it was just
like that was even though i didn't even
have nothing to do with the [ __ ] like i
don't know nothing about nothing like
but just because they just hear my name
floating around some [ __ ]
they call me into like the little school
police call me in the office start
asking me a whole bunch of questions
whatever i'm like bro i don't know what
you're talking about but just because it
hit the desk wrong bro they sent me up
to opportunity school and then i got
kicked at opportunity school and then i
went to court continuation and from
court continuation i just never made it
back to it bro i got too old to go so
would you say that like despite getting
a ged
despite being in trouble a lot would you
say you were a good student or like what
kind of student i probably could have
been a better one but i feel like
teachers ain't as hands-on it's more of
it was more of to me like a paycheck
like instead of seeing like maybe this
kid could be something special they just
they're showing up for the paycheck and
they're underpaid anyway a lot they i
feel like a lot there's only a couple in
the school that i feel like in
everything
really give a [ __ ] like yeah the checks
it's all right whatever but i care about
these kids these kids have grown on me
man you don't you don't have you don't
see that especially i feel like nowadays
is worse it's way worse yeah cause like
with the inflation teachers really don't
make [ __ ] because they're paying gone up
so it's like they're still making that
[ __ ] money it's bad bro it's bad
it's bad it's crazy at what point in
time did you first like start getting
familiar with the street [ __ ] like was
like at what age
like 13 13 so that's like at least
because that's when i start like getting
hungry like and wanting things i'm like
[ __ ] i can't really eat like this or do
something like this so i gotta get on
the streets and i gotta make it happen
bruh i gotta i gotta make something i
gotta do something right try a man's man
young trying to sell crack for a short
amount of time that [ __ ] died out quick
because like that was the ending error
crack area yeah i wasn't in the 80s
when it was popping so you know i'm [ __ ]
early early 2000s just catching some
stragglers like it wasn't really
something super crazy like what
what was after that i feel like
[ __ ] were good listen to me bro
i always been good with [ __ ] and when
i saw like it was just even just having
them just around like just always having
like i'm saying so i just started like
kind of pressing like hey let's do this
or you know i'm saying you want to get
on it and a lot of [ __ ] already be
down they already was ready to ride
that's crazy and then from there it was
like i found my my niche i found yeah i
felt like it you know i felt like it was
something i could do oh can i do this
forever but then i start getting older
bro and just
you grow man like you know i just start
getting older man and just start like
[ __ ] man i know i gotta come up with
some type of game plan and this ain't
even [ __ ] like a podcast or nothing
like i don't give a [ __ ] if it's just
owning a business owning something i'm
saying doing anything i don't give a
[ __ ] podcasting was the last
[ __ ] thing on the list
man you're so great at it man i just uh
i touched the microphone and i ain't
left yeah hmm did you ever try did you
ever rap
for a little bit but i did it because it
was like a release
like i liked it because it you know what
i'm saying like i can go talk my [ __ ] on
it but like i never really i feel like
you'd be like a natural dope rapper it
was it was cool man but you know trying
to do it within a group you know and
would just whip people or things like
you're always been a good team player
you know what i'm saying like always
been like yeah just with some of my
people right and just always been a good
team player but
you know [ __ ] don't always play
like that so you know things always you
know break up and i was just like man i
just i think it kind of beat me out of
it like i was like how many years were
you trying
probably like
three three years [ __ ] yeah like three
yeah
in vegas yeah
that vegas rap scene is lit bro i love
it out there it's cool i like the better
they have battles and all that i just
feel like it gets robbed of its shine
too
a lot of cities do but if we're going to
talk about vegas i feel like vegas it
gets robbed of it on me and everybody
that is from there that that raps that
even knows of me knows i'm telling the
truth they get robbed of it they don't
get the same type of opportunities to go
shut [ __ ] down like getting calls like
hey we're taking 90 y'all 10 of y'all a
month let's get across the country ain't
nobody getting them [ __ ] phone calls
like that that's right and everything
that they're probably getting is is
coming from out of town and then even
the [ __ ] you were saying like people
don't know like neos from vegas i think
he went to rancho yeah it went to rancho
and like i'm like yo you would never
know that because then you don't really
rep vegas like you know you know what i
mean but it was on his id one time when
he got pulled over in a little prank
like little [ __ ] right pulled out his id
and it says why does it say north las
vegas but he was claiming l.a yeah it
was like oh i went to school there like
nobody nobody really i don't know i just
don't get that part of it bro like if
you i'm saying like i got love for
mandego and vegas like but if you could
show some love man like don't
show some love let them know where
you're from man let them know where
where your background come from but
everybody always try to hide it like
they're hiding something
i don't i don't get that part like you
could tell your story like why why hide
something if you want to be from l.a hey
all right go ahead and say that hey i'm
from here but by way of here do whatever
you do but just keep that [ __ ] abandoned
100 man keep that [ __ ] 100 so you said
that uh in like high school you had kind
of figured out that there there was a
pathway to kind of get the money that
you were seeking
through your natural talents with women
oh yeah at what age would you say you
had your first you know situation where
there was a nice business situation
going based on those talents
like it really struck good for me
like 15. wow 14 and 15. this is just one
or multiple just one at the time i mean
[ __ ] i didn't really i don't even think
i was ready for multiple [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like i'm trying to get
my feet wet i'm trying to figure it out
myself like is this even something
that's going to even work for me [ __ ]
you know what i mean right i'm just
trying it because i'm like well [ __ ]
it's already there i hadn't tried
everything else i didn't try you know
what i'm saying that's not working right
let me try something let me try
something else and voila appreciate
y'all watching but listen our partners
at blue chew they got you handled fellas
and etc whatever you are they got it if
you got a dick blue chew is for you
because they will make sure your dick
performs at all time levels i mean like
lebron his first three seasons with the
heat type levels i mean your wife will
thank you for it everybody will thank
you for it [ __ ] even if you just take a
blue chew and jerk your dick it's a it's
a stronger jerk i swear to god stronger
[ __ ] jerk for sure you're gonna be
beating your dick like i stole something
so what you gotta do is go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg right now and
you're gonna get your first month free
and this is the great thing about
bluechu the same active ingredients as
viagra and as cialis
but you don't got to go to the doctor's
office yeah who wants to go hang out at
the doctor's office and be like hey doc
you got some [ __ ] pills for me nobody
wants to do that no you sign up at blue
chew use the promo code bootleg and
you're getting your first month
delivered to your door
in discreet packaging i'm telling you
you're going to thank me later all right
if you've gotten bluetooth already just
dm me tell me just just dm me no photos
just tell me know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue chew he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview now that um
you're kind of like
gathering like national fame like i just
saw andrew andrew scholes was talking
about you on uh on on one of his
podcasts and i know he went and trolls
is [ __ ] dope but um now that you're
kind of like getting this newfound fame
like uh
is it like weird or is it something that
you feel like you're kind of built for
because i feel like now you probably get
recognized you go to the mall for like
[ __ ] that like
for just doing a podcast like is it is
it kind of crazy to adjust to that man i
got stopped i was driving in last night
right it's funny yeah i was driving in
last night and i stopped uh
like in the bar store real quick and i
was just i was running in to use the
bathroom and just top off some gas real
quick for you getting that light for get
too expensive you know and i go in the
store and this dude man
sharp from [ __ ] it was the
clerk sharp for [ __ ] shark tank
like bro i don't mean to bother you can
i get a picture with you real quick i'm
on the phone bro i'm trying to just get
my gas and give me i'm like damn is that
the payment for gas like yeah it's like
do i have to still give you my card he
was like i got to get a picture first
wow i was like all right bro you know
it's cool but i like i don't uh
i don't
like i don't look at myself like that
bro i'm just full of people like i just
[ __ ] with the people if you [ __ ] with me
i'm [ __ ] with you you know you want
to build on something you come up
talking the right [ __ ] hey let's build
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying that's
what it's about connecting yeah
connection
it just got to be weird like i feel like
you you your fame obviously
the youtube interviews were big but then
this podcast i feel like this [ __ ] is
just man i feel like it is it's
definitely uh it's a quick obsession
it's different bro like i said and just
going back to what i was saying earlier
just working with people that i've never
i probably would have never in a million
years worked with if i was just staying
in that lane
saying i would have never probably ran
across them hell i never watched any i
never watched anything like that like i
just you know i did my own thing man i
never right has there been a celebrity
or somebody who you admired that like
you found out was like [ __ ] with the
podcast that you kind of were like oh
[ __ ] like i just mentioned andrew
scholes is a fan like anybody like that
yeah uh
macklemore shout out to macklemore man
bruh that's my homie right there how did
you find out he [ __ ] with you one of
my people told me like hey you know
mclemore follows you i said no no
i'm saying football players bruh [ __ ]
rappers
they [ __ ] with me and i [ __ ] with them
[ __ ] macklemore is pretty crazy shout
out to seattle i [ __ ] with him bro yeah
y'all chop it up huh yeah chopped it up
with him yes
yeah he's cool who's your football team
bro
why are you worried about that because
you're trying to get it yeah you're
trying to help you're like listen
cause i grew up i'm from the old school
i grew up as a cowboy i was going to say
if i had to put money on the cowboys
though but troy aikman days though when
they was really playing football bruh
not this [ __ ] that's going on you all
need to get you all weather together how
you feeling about the cowboys man it's
been a while
it's been been a long time man
i don't think they're building around
that the right way
i just think i don't think so mike mike
mccarthy is a terrible coach
but i'm feeling like this they're not
putting the right pieces around then
they got cd lamb they got michael gallup
they got yeah
still developing no offense to them
right right still in development right
not saying they can't be nothing
right now but right still kind of in
development
these are going to be stars here shortly
in the future but right they don't have
like jamar chase are we talking about a
championship here right no you're right
you're right this upcoming year we
talking about one in the next four right
right because i need to know the
difference you know i'm saying so that
way then we can start counting some
people no that's fair but i feel like
some people need to really develop and
i'm sure there's other things going on
like that they probably shouldn't have
paid zeke that bag because who pays
running backs like that you know you
know the poller dude
i was watching the uh the hard knocks
[ __ ] shout out to hard knocks which one
is the lions one that i was watching
listen yeah so and this is no offense to
the lions or anybody but just watching
what some of these teams go through that
still stay low ranking y'all go through
hell in a cell with 83 man i'm saying 83
man that y'all start off with and y'all
got to keep 52 or something [ __ ] i think
it's 52 or 53. yeah so there's people
that you got to cut you go through all
this hell to still have a [ __ ] up year
the worst it's crazy to me i was like
damn i never thought i was like damn
there is but the money's not terrible
the money's not terrible you know i
heard uh what was that
they say uh
for like even the practice team if you
like still make the practice team but
not being on something it's like ten
bands a week yeah you'll take that off a
week from the
last like
so let's see september to february
so if you if you make the super bowl
you're there until february so probably
september to january yeah
18 it's 18 weeks at 10 bananas a week at
10 bands a week real quick and you're
not even playing it's 180 bands just to
chill [ __ ] work a couple days a week i
need to pick up a player let me know man
i thought some cleats on you could be
like you just be the star the starters
like you know the guy the starters beat
up on makes 10 bands in a week what
40k a month
to just be okay at football
10k just for the practice team you know
what i'm saying because i guess they
keep a practice team around or whatever
have you seen the uh have you like gone
to a raiders game yet
i'm going to uh the raiders cardinals
game like ufc [ __ ] oh do you have
seashells crazy i went to uh actually me
and
well no jumper myself everybody i'm
saying like all the hosts we went to um
to the mas vidal kobe covington fight in
vegas that was pretty cool at floor
seats
what how would you compare the ufc [ __ ]
to the boxing [ __ ] in vegas cause
they're both their own thing i don't
know like because the boxing [ __ ] like
i went to a pacquiao fight in like 2010
or 11 that was [ __ ] insane like i
think the hardest i think one of the
hardest who i watched the most like
honestly like i feel like he is the
future coming up behind florida's
javonte davis right to me i know people
might have their opinions right right
that's fair him devin haney them guys
are the ones coming up uh to female
hopefully man he can get uh get his [ __ ]
together you know what i'm saying but
like they're supposed to be the faces of
boxing i mean i believe they they face
bring them out is the is the environment
different though from a ufc fight to go
into a boxing fight in vegas
is it a different feel a different
environment oh most definitely because
like you see the punches like that's
cool with the uh with boxing and i love
boxing i grew up on boxing watching mike
tyson
but like with
ufc like when you're there and you see
you hear a [ __ ] like get
slammed it like echoes through this [ __ ]
like you just hear a doof it's just a
lot more blood everybody start going
crazy yeah it's crazy crazy you see [ __ ]
live is like uh it's dope it feels like
you know when you when you think about
like people used to go to the roman
coliseum back in the day and watch
people just like brawl yeah nate diaz
come get the interview boy i'm waiting
on you all y'all stockton's finest come
on bro hey come get it with a real one
bruh real to recognize real come on and
come get it have you reached out to the
ideas outside of right now
i think i talked to
a publisher i talked to her about
getting to it but i think i even dm'd
him just on some [ __ ] like man whoop
that whipped that boy ass yeah just on
some regular [ __ ] i couldn't help myself
is that like uh who who are like three
or four people who
you know
you would just love to interview whether
it's a nate diaz or just somebody like
that that you're just a fan of it you're
like man i would just name diaz i'd like
to get him up in there kevin gates i'd
like to get him up in there because i
always know he got some wild [ __ ] to say
super wild andrew tate yeah come on come
run it okay me and you we gotta run one
up youtube interview might get pulled
down
it might get pulled but you know what i
know how to navigate the conversation so
i think that we might be able to do good
and just do the numbers even though i
know it's going to be peaking the
[ __ ] ceiling it's going to be oozing
you might have to go to romania for that
but you know hey man it might be worth
it it might be [ __ ] worth it it would
be worth it it would you know i'm making
the move bro you got to make sure
wherever hey wherever
hey wherever it takes me me and my
spanish guitar what were you thinking
like when you
when you saw him get banned off the
internet like what were your thoughts on
that
that's just you know
you and i both know okay when it comes
to radio when it comes to social content
when it comes to any kind of content
there's always a cap of what they feel
you can say so you don't disturb society
right that's pretty much what it is and
they they capped him that's what i look
at it as he he tried to see how deep the
rabbit hole goes and
it started hitting rock
yeah that makes any sense like no
freaking i'm not mad at him because i'll
say this like you know you want to be
open hey be open do your thing brother i
ain't got nothing against that but
that's what they're gonna do to you
they're gonna try to cap you man there's
too many people that run that [ __ ] on
the other side that's just you're
outnumbered right it's just a slippery
slope when you start banning people
because it's like okay so now that it's
a precedent that people can just be
deleted off the internet it's like just
like that and like obviously if you
eaten like that yeah first of all he was
eating crazy but also like i would say
like 90 of what andrew tate was saying
was probably like
i wouldn't say rat i mean like i could
understand like yeah yeah he's just his
delivery might be you know but whatever
i get it he's he's you know i would say
the other 10 might be a little
problematic if like 12 year old kids are
watching it on tick tock but at that
same time it's no different than when
you and i were growing up and [ __ ]
eminem came out talking about raping his
mom we didn't go [ __ ] rape our mom
you know what i'm trying like right
right right like at the end of the day
because i think that's really probably
the biggest concern was like well his
main audience are kids and we don't want
kids growing up being yeah
yeah they don't but but it's like if
you're doing your job as parents because
i feel like there's a and i'm not going
to speak on what but i feel like there's
a lot of other things that they let just
naturally organically be be some
encouragement
and they don't mind that and i don't
want to speak on things because i want
to get tons of stuff whether it's music
whether it's
a lot of stuff that they say hey let
them have a choice so like come on man
like open if you're going to open it up
open it up yeah i just you know if
you're going to open up the [ __ ] door
don't crack it right open the door right
right don't try to find things that okay
this this passes
oh okay and this passes no you don't you
stand over here to the side of the line
we'll talk to you in a second
all right this one passes y'all three go
over to this side like come on man it's
like this wild and crazy [ __ ] if you're
good that's being marketing to kids is
okay it's okay but this [ __ ] y'all gotta
it's oh it might just disturb these kids
it might give them the
a false sense of something they don't
need to be believing in or looking at
but like come on man who's controlling
this
like who's controlling these narratives
like who's making up these shitty ass
[ __ ] rules of what they feel like
society
it's really all the tech companies man
and it's like crazy because like you
said it's like controls the tech
companies
right oh you don't want to talk about it
mark zuckerberg i don't [ __ ] know
mark zuckerberg goddamn yeah what's the
other guy who runs google right i think
it's an asian guy right now you know
where i'm going with it it ain't just
him
look at him bro joe byron
no presidente joe sleepy joe i don't
[ __ ] know
i i i don't know who man uh like i said
i just know that like
if you're gonna long story short and
keep it for what it is if you're gonna
crack the door
open it up yeah like to me to me it's a
slippery slope when you make a bunch of
this [ __ ] okay whatever this is all your
favorite words that's a slippery slope
you've used that a few times now so if
all this is okay right yeah but then
this little like
that isn't even necessarily maybe as
outrageous as some of the stuff over
here yeah yeah
but you know like i said
this is rules people make up man are you
worried about that like are you worried
like um
you know like when you when you when you
when you do certain content like yeah
you know uh
does it ever cross your mind when you
see something like what happens to
andrew tate like oh maybe i gotta tone
it down a little maybe i gotta i mean i
feel like mine's more of a figure of
speech i'm actually talking to the
person that i'm saying it about versus
doing just a video sitting there
speaking this to everybody putting it
out in the world this is a real time of
how i feel and a real interaction with
somebody and i feel like people if you
if you're
if you're smart you know how to separate
the two right you know what i'm saying
so that's how i really feel about it we
got to stop the interview tell you about
our partners at odd socks well first of
all let's check out the brand new collab
look at these
the bootleg kev sock you see my pink ass
face on those [ __ ] socks nobody wants
to buy those we're gonna figure out a
way to give them away though uh but look
odd socks the most comfortable socks in
the world um and the best thing about
odd socks is they're our family man i've
been walking with these guys for about
10 years now and i will not wear
anything else on my feet like i swear to
god i'm about to take my shoe off i'm
about to take the look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an awesome basic you
know what i'm saying we [ __ ] with odd
socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about nickelodeon
shout out to patrick [ __ ]
cheez-its
baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little pop-tart underwear yeah i
mean
yeah these are the odd socks basics all
right so if you go to the website right
now order you some underwear order you
some socks use the promo code bootleg
kev that's one word all together bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off at checkout
go to
oddsoxofficial.com one more time that's
oddssodgeofficial.com promo code bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off your order
of course we're presented by odd socks
and we are proud to say so all right
let's get back to the interview
what's next for you man i mean you said
you didn't want to share too much but
obviously the podcast is booming um
i you gotta what's next for sharp
probably movies man movies yeah yeah any
interest so far and yeah yeah i got some
about to go work on next month wow yeah
acting
i like it man trying something man just
hey man
they hit me i like it i think it's
something that's fitting for myself i'll
roll with it have you already shot some
stuff or is it as is yeah i've had to do
a couple of like you know little
monologues and [ __ ] like that so you
know i didn't just get picked i had to
kind of run through it a little bit they
saw me but was that difficult like i
always wonder what that's like to like
sit down and like sit in front of some
strangers and be like hey do this no no
natural
that's beautiful man so you're gonna be
in movies the podcast is going crazy
how many times you're dropping once a
week right just uh i just signed on with
um a device company called hamilton
devices man they make a lot of different
like weed devices [ __ ] like that you
know what i mean like
they they they're [ __ ] with me so
like i've just been getting different
endeavors sushi tenco man shout out to
them man been my people since day one
like just you know just different
endeavors manscape shout out to manscape
man go if you [ __ ] with manscape go
on there hey man use the coach
shut that [ __ ] out yeah use the code
sharp tank man to get 15 off all your
merchandise people be [ __ ] with it
man like i got i got hey yo that [ __ ]
works and that [ __ ] works i got good
sponsors that stand behind me go to
hamilton.com use sharp 15. man to get 15
off the whole store and they got some
crazy ass devices
just check it out like devices yeah the
[ __ ] that i [ __ ] with like is
like i like top-notch everything so if
people looking for top-notch everything
that i'm sponsored by is top-notch have
you turned down some [ __ ] because it
didn't really align with your v like
maybe your brand or like
of course like if like yo adam's like
hey we have a sponsorship here for sharp
tank
i'm good i i know what i like about adam
is because
he's been around it so he he knows with
the pitch my way already i haven't had
it he gets it yeah i haven't had him
bring me anything or even josh bring me
anything that's like hey
yeah like do this like it might be
fitting i'm like nah like i no they
bring me everything's been great um i've
known adam for a long time man i always
been a great dude stand up dude what do
you think are some of the biggest like
misconceptions about adam because i feel
like he kind of gets
misjudged a lot people think that he's a
culture vulture but and all in all bro
he giving [ __ ] a chance and it
worked
that's what [ __ ] people up it's not
that they feel like that it's that the
truth is he did he took a crazy ass
chance and it worked
that throws everybody off you know what
i'm saying like oh [ __ ] he didn't have
to plan it he didn't have to do this no
the piece is just kinda
it all happened super organically and
super fast and something kudos to him
for having like that eye for
saying like oh [ __ ] this dude sharp
might be great if he did a podcast tried
me [ __ ] a.d did numbers yeah first one's
sitting at
2 million now that's crazy first one i
ever did with blue jasmine shout out to
you baby wherever you are
hope your career hope everything booming
for you hope you still if you're selling
them clothes i'll add me i know you're
still selling clothes
what's been your biggest interview so
far views wise
or episodes yeah uh the biggest episode
i did was tucker i think that was
sitting at almost it's headed to 3
million that [ __ ] was crazy
she was crazy [ __ ] clustered [ __ ] bro
because that was like two or three right
that was like quit that was like one of
the first few yeah that was i want to
say
yeah that was some of the first that was
some of the few i just remember like it
was like viral and like my boy's like yo
this dude from phoenix got roasted
i watched that [ __ ] i was like oh man
he's cool ain't nothing against him i
just he didn't know me hey and he turned
it into a bag i think he was selling
like toe sucker shirts or hats or
something [ __ ] something yeah i don't as
you should right [ __ ] it do your thing
do what you got to do bro i'm not here
to stop you to hate on you
the movie uh hopefully coming soon
movies acting netflix shows do
everything bro would you ever do um ted
talks
i feel like you'd be like a great like
inspirational speaker like you know how
they hire people to go speak to like
conferences with people would you ever
do that [ __ ] yeah for sure i feel like
you should do it i think it'll be i
think it'll be dope man i think you know
just to kind of open people up to my
philosophy and hopefully they can open
me up to theirs you know i think that's
what it's all about man just coming
together and sharing new ideas
new things and you know it doesn't
really shouldn't really matter man your
background man it should matter you know
where your mind's at you know where
you're trying to head to where you're
going you can't you can't knock nobody
for really trying to to
take a change to it that's fair man
i feel like you should um you should do
like a piece of content like once a
month like where you're just like you
have like a monologue or you have just
like
where it's not necessarily an interview
but it's you just
sharing a tidbit man yeah some
motivational words some yeah i was
talking to
i think i was talking to uh
trev talking to trev shout out to trev
does uh he's a cameraman at no jumper
and me and him was talking because me
and him
we worked together a lot like on the
vlogs and [ __ ] like that right he would
do vlogs like he would take me whatever
you don't say we'd do the vlogs together
they would go up yeah and he was telling
me he said man you should do something
like that you know we were we were
talking so i don't know we might have
something in the works you know me and
just got to sit down and no i think that
[ __ ] will go crazy especially
tick tock all that [ __ ] that [ __ ] would
go up man yeah everybody already clips
my my [ __ ] anyway my name is clip it you
might as well they clip it anyway
already 100 man uh anybody uh that you
want to shout out uh obviously we talked
about las vegas any any vegas mc's or
san diego mc's you're [ __ ] what do
you want to show shout out to listen man
shout out to all of [ __ ] shout out to
all of vegas you know i'm saying shout
out to everybody across the
[ __ ] country man shout out to
no jumper everybody that working no
jumper all the way to the man who
pressed the button on the camera i love
y'all man you know what we doing you
know where we at man what time zone we
on man we're on the bootleg care podcast
my bro i appreciate you last question
better mexican food between
la
san diego
and an underrated candidate in las vegas
san diego the best i think san diego was
the best mexican food ever i agree i i
gotta that's that was easy really and
you can just cross the border and go to
tijuana and it gets way better bro man
i'm telling you bro ain't nothing like
it